[Música]
extienden el estado de emergencia en
Perú el gobierno decretó que a partir de
hoy y durante 30 días la medida también
se aplicará a las regiones de Lima y
cusco el objetivo es controlar las
protestas que han dejado 49 personas
muertas
en el marco del aniversario número 31 de
los acuerdos de paz en El Salvador
cientos de personas salieron a las
calles para rechazar varias medidas del
presidente nayib bukele como el régimen
de excepción que ha provocado
detenciones arbitrarias y sus
aspiraciones de un segundo mandato
a 30 aumentó el número de muertos por
los ataques del sábado en la ciudad
ucraniana de Nitro el presidente
volodínsky dijo que continúan las
labores de rescate y que otras 30
personas se encuentran desaparecidas
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz comenzamos en Perú entró en
vigor el estado de emergencia decretado
este sábado por el gobierno y extendido
hacia otras regiones del país la
decisión se debe a las manifestaciones
que no se debilitan desde la destitución
del presidente Pedro Castillo el pasado
7 de diciembre y que hasta el momento
han dejado 49 personas muertas con esta
medida se autoriza al ejército a
intervenir para mantener el orden
durante 30 días nuestro corresponsal
Francisco Zacarías Se fue hasta la
ciudad de puno en el sur de la frontera
con Bolivia donde justamente empezó el
estado de emergencia
la región puno se alista entrar en toque
de queda desde las 8 de la noche hasta
las cuatro de la mañana del día
siguiente la medida regirá durante 10
días la fuerzas de seguridad patrullarán
las calles y se ha ordenado que la
población se mantenga en sus casas el
gobierno de la presidenta Dina boluarte
también declaró el estado de emergencia
durante 30 días en Lima callao puno
cusco y otras provincias del país el
estado de emergencia Busca frenar la
marcha de protesta y el viaje a Lima de
miles de manifestantes que tienen
previsto realizar contra la presidenta
Dina boluarte y el congreso ellos
también exigen el adelanto de elecciones
para este año y una nueva constitución
hoy uno y juliaca su principal ciudad
que son el corazón de las protestas se
encuentran en tensa calma debido a que
los manifestantes dieron una tregua para
que la población se abastezca de
alimentos pero el transporte público es
restringido por la presencia de bloqueos
precisamente la sociedad peruana de
hidrocarburos ha revelado que las
regiones del Sur del se verán afectadas
por el desabastecimiento de combustibles
debido al bloqueo de carreteras al
respecto a la superintendencia de
transportes señaló que hay más de 120
puntos de tránsito interrumpidos 19 vías
nacionales afectadas que impactan
negativamente a once regiones siendo
cusco y puno las más perjudicadas
Mientras tanto en Lima así como en otras
ciudades del Sur del Perú Se realizaron
misas por los fallecidos durante las
jornadas de protesta vamos a Brasil tras
el intento golpista sucedido el pasado 8
de enero en Brasil y al presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva se ha visto
fortalecido luego de encontrar respaldo
en la institucionalidad brasileña la
población civil e incluso la comunidad
internacional Mientras tanto las
investigaciones en contra del
expresidente bolsonaro aumentan y su
imagen se ve fuertemente afectada veamos
el análisis de Andrés triviño
Lula estaría sacando provecho de los
bochornosos sucesos del pasado 8 de
enero desde que empezaron las
investigaciones de los hechos todo
parece fortalecer al recién posesionado
presidente
de enero se ha puesto en una situación
bastante difícil Incluso en el ámbito
político
en personas políticas no han tratado de
demarcarse como en contra de lo que ha
sucedido la rápida actuación de las
autoridades logró que los ataques
vandálicos a las sedes del Congreso la
Corte Suprema y la presidencia fueron
controlados en menos de cinco horas un
hecho que produjo que miles de personas
salieran a las calles de todo el país a
manifestarse en contra del asalto
incluyendo la participación de
representantes estatales y legisladores
de todos los sectores políticos la firma
de atafolia señaló que el 93% de los
brasileños condenan los ataques mientras
que un 55% considera que bolsonaro
estuvo involucrado en los hechos a nivel
internacional organizaciones como la ONU
y la Unión Europea expresaron su apoyo a
Lula
incluso líderes conservadores que han
apoyado bolsonaru como el Primer
Ministro israelí Benjamín netanyahu y el
expresidente colombiano Álvaro Uribe
hicieron un llamado a respetar la
democracia
Parece ser que la extrema derecha en las
Américas No pues va perdiendo fuerza en
el sentido de que tuvimos a Trump en
Estados Unidos que ha salido del Poder y
además de eso pues está ahí también
enfrentándose a la justicia en Estados
Unidos y vemos en otros países de
América Latina la extrema derecha pues
perdiendo su espacio político no las
investigaciones en contra de bolsonario
continúan y más de 1800 personas han
sido detenidas entre ellas Anderson
Torres quien sirvió al ex mandatario
como suministro de Justicia una ficha
clave que podría empeorar la para
bolsonaruga organizaciones de la
sociedad civil y de diferentes
comunidades de El Salvador salieron a
las calles de San Salvador para
conmemorar el aniversario de los
acuerdos de paz de 1992 que terminaron
Con 12 años de un conflicto armado que
dejó más de 75.000 víctimas en ese país
centroamericano los manifestantes
también rechazaron el régimen de
excepción que impuso el presidente nayib
bukele para controlar a las pandillas y
su intención de correr en las
presidenciales de 2024
la paz vuelve al debate organizaciones
de Derechos Humanos Víctimas de la
guerra grupos opositores y ex
guerrilleros conmemoraron el 31
aniversario de la firma de los acuerdos
de paz que terminaron con la guerra
civil salvadoreña de los años 80 un
aniversario sin actos oficiales ya que
el gobierno de nayib bukele no reconoce
la fecha por diferencias políticas
que los acuerdos de paz fueron una farsa
cuando miles de personas murieron
fallecieron y existe impunidad en este
país de muchos casos que se dieron los
manifestantes rechazaron la intención de
reelección presidencial de bukele en
2024 y la imposición de un régimen de
excepción que según cifras oficiales ha
dejado más de 60.000 detenciones
criticadas por organismos de Derechos
Humanos
expresarme por las injusticias que se
están dando más que todo por la captura
de gente inocente Pues porque sin
antecedentes penales sin antecedentes
policiales no creemos en el hecho que
estos
la fiscalía y el mismo gobierno de que
es procurar justicia Este no es un hecho
de procurar justicia Entonces nos
preguntamos Cuál es la verdadera
intención de estos hechos es claramente
un ataque y una venganza política contra
nuestros territorios organizados los
denominados acuerdos de paz de
Chapultepec en 1992 Fueron liderados por
Naciones Unidas y pusieron fin a uno de
los conflictos más sangrientos de
América Latina que dejó más de 75.000
Muertos Nueva York se alista para el
juicio por narcotráfico contra el ex
secretario de seguridad de México Genaro
García Luna y el más importante desde el
juicio contra El Chapo Guzmán en 2019
este es el funcionario mexicano de más
alto Rango en ser juzgado en una extensa
persecución de Estados Unidos contra
narcotraficantes y su complicidad con
distintos gobiernos de América los
fiscales acusan a García Luna de aceptar
millonarios sobornos para permitir que
el cartel de Sinaloa enviar a toneladas
de droga a territorio estadounidense
entre 2001 y 2012 la periodista de
investigación cubano mexicana penilé
Ramírez quien ha seguido el caso durante
años explicó Cuál es la importancia de
este juicio Cómo este hombre que venía
de un origen humilde creció en una
familia humilde siempre trabajó como
funcionario público salió del gobierno
como millonario parte de lo que va a
responder este juicio es cómo lo logró Y
por supuesto la acusación que hay por
parte de la fiscalía es que lo logró
recibiendo sobornos multimillonarios del
Cartel De Sinaloa para ayudarlos a
traficar más de 50 toneladas de cocaína
a mí me parece que
el juicio no ha recibido la atención que
merece en Estados Unidos y en la prensa
en inglés en Estados Unidos y creo que
es principalmente porque no se ha
hablado lo suficiente de lo que para mí
es el ángulo más importante de esta
historia que es cuánto sabía la DEA de
las actividades supuestas actividades de
García Luna y cuando lo supo los
extremos climáticos tienen en emergencia
a dos estados de Estados Unidos primero
el presidente Joe biden declaró la
alerta para California el sábado por las
tormentas que han dejado al menos 19
personas muertas desde diciembre y hoy
el mandatario decretó la emergencia para
Alabama por los tornados
entre inundaciones y tornados están los
estados de California y Alabama en
Estados Unidos los habitantes de
bradbull en cercanías de Montgomery
recogen los escombros que han dejado los
destructivos vientos su casa ya había
sido devastada en un tornado anterior la
primera vez que nos golpeó fue el
Tornado f1 pero solo se llevó la casa
eso fue malo pero todavía tenía mi
negocio todavía podía ir a trabajar esta
vez tan pronto como salí Caminé
alrededor vi la tienda y todos mis
camiones de trabajo y herramientas
desaparecidas al menos seis personas
murieron el jueves en el centro de ese
Estado Sureño a causa de las tormentas
eléctricas y uno de los tornados que
azotaron la región
a mí me parece raro que esto ocurra más
en invierno Esta no es la típica
temporada de tornados así Que supongo
que mi mayor problema es el hecho de que
parece estar ocurriendo más a menudo
fuera de temporada
mientras en California lluvia fuertes
vientos e inundaciones han azotado el
estado desde de diciembre caitlyn dice
que no estaba preparada para que el agua
subiera tanto en estado de shock porque
a pesar de que nos preparamos para ello
no nos preparamos para que llegue Tan
Alto Como lo hizo por lo que fue más lío
más destrucción casi 23.000 hogares y
negocios se quedaron sin electricidad el
sábado en los dos estados el presidente
biden decretó el estado de emergencia
para ayudar a los habitantes con la
crisis agilizando el envío de ayudas
federales El Sistema Meteorológico da
una luz de esperanza y dice que el clima
cederá la próxima semana
pasamos a Ucrania a 30 subió el número
de muertos por el ataque contra un
edificio Residencial en la ciudad de
Nitro y por el que el gobierno ucraniano
culpa a Rusia se trata del siniestro más
mortífero para civiles en varios meses
así lo explica desde Ucrania nuestra
mirada especial Catalina Gómez Ángel
ha caído la noche en Ucrania y a esta
hora continúan la búsqueda de
sobrevivientes en ese edificio
Residencial de la ciudad de denipro que
fue atacada ayer durante ese ataque con
misiles masivos llevado a cabo por el
gobierno de Moscú que a propósito hoy
dijo que había alcanzado todos los
objetivos con ese ataque aunque no se
refirió exactamente a este edificio las
imágenes que han quedado con este ataque
tienen conmovido a los ucranianos que en
las últimas semanas y meses habían visto
como estos misiles Y estos drones
kamikasis alcanzaban especialmente la
infraestructura eléctrica y otra
infraestructura importante en el país
pero no eran ataques tan masivos a
lugares con habitados por civiles como
el que sucedió ayer que hace recordar
otro ataque muy grande que sucedió en la
ciudad de kramators que en el donde nos
encontramos esta noche cuando en abril
otro ataque O al menos 60 personas
fallecidas y casi un centenar de heridos
de decenas y decenas de personas que en
ese momento estaban allí esperando ser
evacuadas de la ciudad pero entonces los
rusos negaron haber hecho este ataque
algo que no hicieron hoy
el presidente de Israel Isaac gersox se
pronunció sobre el descontento que ha
desatado el plan de reforma al sistema
judicial del Primer Ministro Benjamín
que normalmente ejerce un papel
simbólico y carece de poderes ejecutivos
dijo que estaba reuniéndose con varias
figuras políticas y mediando entre las
partes para evitar lo que denominó como
una crisis constitucional histórica a
pesar de las críticas netanyahu reiteró
su intención de seguir adelante con su
proyecto
y en nepal un avión se estrelló cuando
aterrizaban el aeropuerto recién
inaugurado de la ciudad turística de
pocara Hasta el momento las autoridades
confirman que 68 de los 72 pasajeros
murieron Mientras que otras cuatro
personas se encuentran desaparecidas aún
no está claro que produjo la emergencia
en el vuelo
momentos antes del desastre ciudadanos
captaron en cámara los últimos instantes
del atr 72 que perdía el control cerca
de una zona Residencial instantes
después una potente explosión este
testigo estaba presente cerca del lugar
de la peor tragedia aérea de nepal en
los últimos 30 años
cuando el avión hizo un fuerte ruido nos
volvimos y vimos caer un árbol de bambú
le dije a mi amigo que el avión estaba
cayendo al suelo y oímos el sonido de
una explosión El avión de la compañía GT
Airlines procedía de la capital catmundú
debía aterrizar en el aeropuerto local
de la ciudad turística de pocora en el
centro del país en el viajaban 72
personas entre ellas seis niños y cuatro
miembros de la tripulación las
autoridades confirmaron la muerte de 68
de ellos y debido a la oscuridad se
suspendieron las labores de búsqueda
cuatro restantes el sector del
transporte aéreo de este país ha
experimentado un auge en los últimos
años pero la falta de formación del
personal y el mantenimiento deficiente
de las naves hacen que el peligro sea
una constante nepal el país carece de la
infraestructura necesaria para ofrecer
previsiones meteorológicas precisas
sobre todo en las zonas remotas y de
difícil acceso la Unión Europea prohibió
a las aerolíneas nepalíes de su espacio
aéreo por motivos de seguridad desde
hasta aquí este Informativo en France 24
los invitamos a que continúen con toda
nuestra programación
[Música]